like so many of us kevin hart is trying
to process a lot of different emotions
on one hand he is
thankful and feels blessed that his
family is healthy and happy
meanwhile since the death of george
floyd he is feeling angry
and frustrated getting something off my
chest
i'm watching that narrative slowly
change into the rioting we're not
talking about
why george floyd rests in peace
as we know was killed by a cop
everybody's conversation
should be about the change kevin spoke
directly to his 92 million
instagram followers in a plea to keep
the focus on the social injustice
of what is going on not just the riots
the 40 year old comic has been home in
la with family i spoke with him before
the unrest to promote his new audiobook
family was at the forefront of his mind
kev you were already a workaholic how
are you handling quarantine
where you have to kind of relax you know
what
it's been unreal you know through any
pregnancy
you know my wife now my ex-wife i was
always on the go so i've never been
there
to see like the just the progression
and the mood swing i am now in the
stages of pregnancy
where you got to just shut up eniko
isn't the only lady in kevin's life
calling the shots
when it comes to tick tock
fifteen-year-old daughter heaven takes
center stage
once again i do as i'm told my daughter
is the leader
she's a ring leader can't move her
bottom half though
that's it oh a bunch of this honey let
me see you
do something with your feet dad no come
on you're killing my vibe
speaking of vibes earlier in quarantine
kevin was giving us all
shades of grey i'm not gonna lie to
y'all i'm kind of rolling with the gray
hair
where are your grays bro where are your
grays you're referring to my hair
right yeah of course don't run from it
embrace it
i caught my wife shaking her head
looking at me a couple times
my daughter was like what are you doing
the son started calling me grandpa
asking me where my cane was yeah a whole
bunch of that